hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker I
took a little breather I'm feeling okay
and I think I can do this with perfect
perfection is what I'm aiming for
because when I win when people look at
me they see nothing but perfection they
know that markiplier whoo that is a man
with without parallel that is a man
without hope that's a man who's whose
soul has probably left his body there's
a man who has nothing left to live for
in his life and you know there's more
Mario makers levels to play than just
stupid Rosses levels although I want to
be very clear when I was watching the
game grumps play I thought they were
being a little harsh on Ross unfair it's
I'm bad that's just the only answer that
I have I know this I know this I accept
this I accept this as a part of my
character and I know it's always gonna
live with me I'm just terrible at what I
do in Ross is the saint and lovely
person and I would never ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
say anything bad about him or his mother
or any of his family members for that
matter myself first in the Death Eater
dick Bowser boo he did lovely whoa I
thought you were gonna go a little more
farther than that
thank you eat ten dicks this time Hey
look at me goodbye
that would have been impending death if
I hadn't have actually gone in there
these pipe mechanics need work
someone called Nintendo someone call
everyone's dad on the internet who works
at Nintendo because everyone's that's
the joke and making a making a joke
there all right we got this we rollin
the point is not to be greedy that's all
I got to do easy easy
come on jump already or do your thing
why is he not doing his thing
what is this there he goes huh whoa
yes easy peasy lemon squeeze me alright
now this one I just gotta be a little
patient wait for the first one just pop
them right like that okay there it is oh
oh oh yes oh yes please oh please please
please please yes please
oh god oh god oh no no no no how is this
fair how is this fair okay
so what I got to do is I got to jump
down and grab the spring okay I'm gonna
do first step just drop down easy
don't get hit okay next step grab spring
jump out of way and I'd be fine oh god
oh god oh god okay we're fine we're fine
we got this we got this we got this we
got this we got this okay last Bowser's
last boughs we got this Oh God
oh I forgot about that oh I needed that
oh I had that son of a [ __ ] this is
just a frame I've never seen so many
dicks in one bag it's really amazing
impressive there's a feat of skill my
shoulder didn't good at that I'm gonna
go to that that's actually impressive
huh I did that pretty well maybe I just
gotta tell all the baby bowser to eat my
child right before i die i [ __ ] up i
don't know why i twirled anyway carrying
on ain't no thing but a chicken wing
ain't no thing but a chicken dick what
are you talking about markiplier no
chicken wings it's like a you know it's
a saying it's rhyme ain't no thang but a
chicken wing Oh mark you're so funny ha
don't you wish
aren't you don't you not really care
that you don't have anyone else to play
this with and you don't have you know a
Danny or an errand to be on the couch
sharing fun times laughing with what I
don't need that I'm markiplier I'm I'm a
by myself gamer
yeah you know I'm IND EP and Ont I'm um
I'm a winner you know I'm a winner I
don't need any friends or you know
family or anything like that ok mark
that's pretty good I'm glad that you you
know I've come to terms with that you're
incredibly crippling loneliness what are
you talking about mark
I know lonely I have so many friends
look they're all there I can see him in
the camera in my reflection they're
they're standing behind me all ghostly
apparition like it's nice it's nice
being around people that care and that's
what that's what they are they're
they're they're people that care and
they do care I care about them we care
about each other and we care together
forever and ever let me up I'm going for
Firefly no I'm gonna die apparently I'm
just gonna fall into the pit and die
haha mark that's so ironic because you
said you were gonna do something else
and then you did the not thing isn't
that funny
sure is Mark emus sure is I almost
forgot my spring don't want to forget
that this name of Louisville is
companion spring and that I am NOT happy
inside I have no soul it left in the
middle of the second episode did you see
it if you if you do a flashback you can
actually catch it you can check catch at
the moment it leaves my body it's really
quite amazing actually almost beautiful
as you see the struggling soul inside me
just so happy to be free of this
experience
okay nailing it Hey Oh too close too
close too close but I got this I got
this that louse Bowser was a tune last
Bowser was a chumpy chump and if there's
one thing that I'm not
it is a chump don't even try it yes
you're dead he is dead your friend is
why did I not go up that no oh you yeah
you what oh oh I forgot about that oh my
god oh my god that was amazing oh that
was amazing
okay stop doing that so much yeah it's
so scary oh that was so scary oh I'm so
scared I'm not okay I'm not okay
I forgot that I could do that I forgot
that I could do that oh my god I forgot
that I could do that that's amazing okay
so if I put this here he shouldn't bow
oh I hate this and everyone everyone at
everyone everyone is an ass Rowan is a
bag of giant douche holes don't ask me
what a douche hole is you know what a
douche all is that's for my stupid screw
your face butt out so if I oh oh that's
handy bad oh wow I got a little cocky
there but hey that's an interesting new
development but you know what I'm gonna
forget about that because that's gonna
throw me off and I'm actually gonna try
to beat the game because I'm a winner
I'm a why
I'm a Wang er a wanker when called day
went call night don't you even try to
give me a fright I'll eat your anus well
is that what does John say Cena saying
trainwreck like I don't kick asses I'll
lick him
I'll look Uranus I'll lick your house I
can't even remember it was it was really
funny I didn't even see the movie I just
know that that part from like that movie
that quoted all over the place I think
John Cena should do a lot more comedy
ever since he became the laughingstock
of the internet well actually no not the
laughingstock of the internet he's super
awesome
hopefully I've seen it's not what why
would John seem to be watching my
playthrough nevermind I have irrational
fears sometimes sometimes when I'm in
swimming sometimes when I'm in the
swimming pool I think there's a shark in
the water
hahaha funny anecdote
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get this
it's time for silence and it's time for
cooperation of my brain coordinating my
left and right side cuz usually my left
side is dedicated to generating nothing
but [ __ ] like an endless stream of
[ __ ] I am thinking winning thoughts
and winning is all I've ever known to do
yes okay I am a winner I am winning I'm
gonna win this concentrate every move
every muscle dedicated to exactly what I
need to do at all times at all times
dedicated perfectly
I'm a one-man machine what am I talking
about shut up I don't know I'm a one-man
machine on a one track mission with a
one-track mind who knows what I'm gonna
do next oh wait I do I'm gonna win I'm
going to win that's right that's right
that's wrong that's wrong I can do this
I know I can do this
I feel it in my bones I feel it in my
grundle
oh yeah the grundle senses are tingling
what the [ __ ] am i talking about shut up
doesn't even matter I'm in the zone I'm
in the zone I am a man on a mission
I'm a man with a plan I'm a man who
knows exactly what to do
in some situations not all of them many
many though oh right under your nose
[ __ ] right under your nose okay I got
this I forgot the special suck my dong
powers that's not what I'm thinking of
but you got you guys you guys know what
I'm talking about right when I tell them
this fondled my grundle cool that's
skills right there it's luck pure
unadulterated luck that's what that was
how about you just go eat ten Oh what
are you doing being stupid I gotcha
oh I got you I am a winner look at this
look at me huh
leave me you're on the wrong side now Oh
timing oh yeah yeah okay now this one's
easy
just gotta bond Kip whoa whoa whoa what
that no no oh God
my plane is late but whatever I don't
care
I mean okay this time don't eat a bag of
dicks okay ah oh yes oh yes that is the
one that's not Oh God oh oh oh oh my
heart oh it hurts okay it's still a way
I can do this
Oh God Oh God